MEANS IT'S UNDER CONTROL.
RUSSIA AND LEARNING OF A
UKRAINIAN MAN BURIED ALIVE
ALONGSIDE HIS TWO BROTHERS.
MELISSA BELL "OUTFRONT" TONIGHT
IN KYIV.
>> Reporter: THIS IS WHERE
MIKOLA WAS BURIED ALIVE.
THE BLINDFOLD HE SAYS HE AND HIS
TWO BROTHERS WERE PLAYED TO WEAR
BY RUSSIA'S SOLDIERS STILL
STREWN BY THEIR SHADOW GRAVE.
MIKOLA SHOWS US WHERE THE BULLET
ENTERED HIS CHEEK.
HIS BROTHERS, KILLED, BUT HE
MANAGED TO ESCAPE THEIR TOMB.
>> Translator: I HAD TO LIVE TO
TELL THIS STORY, NOT TO
UKRAINIANS, BUT TO THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: THE REGIONAL
PROSECUTORS OFFICE SAYS A WAR
CRIMES INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
OPENED.
THIS IS MIKOLA'S HOUSE WHERE HE
LIVED WITH HIS TWO BROTHERS
ALONG WITH THEIR SISTER.
ON MARCH 18th, RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
CAME IN LOOKING FOR THE MAN THEY
BELIEVED RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ATTACK ON THEIR CONVOYS AND THAT
IS WHEN THE FAMILY'S NIGHTMARE
BEGAN.
THREE SOLDIERS ENTERED THE
HOUSING LOOKING FOR EVIDENCE TO
LINK THEM TO THE CONVOY, BUT
WHAT THEY DID FIND IS SOMETHING
TO LINK THE FAMILY TO THE
MILITARY IN THE SHAPE OF THEIR
GRANDFATHER'S MILITARY MEDAL.
THEY ALSO FOUND YEVYEN'S
MILITARY BAG, SINCE SERVICE IN
THE UKRAINIAN ARMY, HE WAS
PREPARING TO GO AND FIGHT.
FOR FOUR DAYS, THEIR SISTER
IRENA HEARD NOTHING FROM HER
BROTHERS UNTIL MIKOLA CAME BACK
FROM THE DEAD.
I CAME HOME AND THERE WAS
MIKOLA.
I LOOKED AT HIS EYES AND ASKED
WHERE ARE THE OTHERS?
HE SAID THERE ARE NO OTHERS.
MIKOLA SAYS AFTER BEING TAKEN
FROM THEIR HOME, THE THREE
BROTHERS WERE BLIND-FOLDED AND
INTERROGATED IN CELLAR FOR FOUR
DAYS, THEN BEATEN AND TAKEN TO
THE SITE OF THEIR EXECUTION.
DAYS ON, HE STILL STRUGGLES TO
SPEAK.
WHAT DO I THINK OF THE RUSSIANS?
I HATE THEM, WITH ALL MY SOUL.
THEY ARE ANIMALS.
THEY SHOULD BURN IN HELL.
IT WAS ONLY AFTER THE RUSSIAN
WITHDRAWAL THAT A MONTH AFTER
THEIR EXECUTION, YEFGENI AND
DMITRIA WERE GIVEN A TOMB STONE
AND THE PEACE THAT MIKOLA HAS
BEEN DENIED.
ERIN, IT IS IN THOSE PARTS OF
UKRAINE THAT WERE OCCUPIED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES FOR SOME TIME
THAT SO MANY OF THOSE WAR CRIMES
ARE NOW BEING INVESTIGATED AND
THERE IS, OF COURSE, A SENSE OF
RELIEF NOW IN THOSE PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT OCCUPATION SHOULD
BE OVER.
WORSE NEWS, OF COURSE, FOR
UKRAINIANS AS YOU MENTIONED IN
THE ASOVSTAL STEEL PLANT.
THIS WAS NOT THEIR PREFERRED
OUTCOME.
THESE HAD BE FIGHTERS WHO HAD
BEEN HOLDING OUT, A KEY SYMBOL
OF THEIR RESISTANCE IN THEIR
FIGHT AGAINST RUSSIA.
RUSSIA, THEREFORE, CONFIRMS ITS
CONTROL OVER MARIUPOL BUT GOOD
NEWS FOR THE FAMILIES
IMMEDIATELY INVOLVED AND WILL AT
LEAST BE GETTING THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS HOME, ONCE THEY'RE
TAKEN BACK TO THOSE BORDER
REGIONS OF DONETSK AND AN
EXCHANGE CAN BE ORGANIZED THERE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MELISSA
BELL TONIGHT IN KYIV.
I WANT TO GO NOW TO RETIRED
GENERAL MARK HERTLING, FORMER
COMMANDER GENERAL FOR EUROPE IN
THE SEVENTH ARMY.
YOU HEAR MIKOLA'S STORY AND IT
IS SO HORRIFIC WHAT HAPPENED,
BEATEN, BLINDFOLDED, BOUND WITH
HIS BROTHERS, SHOT, BURIED
ALIVE, ABLE TO ESCAPE, HIS
BROTHERS WERE NOT.
IT'S A HORRIBLE STORY AND YET,
IN A VILLAGE LAST WEEK I HEAR
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, TORTURE WHERE
PEOPLES' FINGER NAILS WERE
RIPPED OFF.
THE STORIES WE'RE HEARING ARE
HORRIBLE.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT WE WILL
STILL HEAR WORSE?
WORSE STORIES INVOLVING RUSSIAN
FORCES?
>> ERIN, YOU CAN WRITE THAT DOWN
AS IT WILL HAPPEN.
WE HAVE SEEN SO MANY HORRIFIC
THINGS, SO MANY CRIMINAL ACTS,
SO MANY ACTS OF DEPRAVITY AND
BEASTIALITY AND SO MANY HORRIBLE
THINGS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
THIS CAMPAIGN AND BOUND TO SEE
MORE.
THIS STORY ABOUT THE TWO
BROTHERS IS JUST, TO ME, JUST
DESPICABLE.
THERE ARE WARS WHERE BROTHERS
HAVE FOUGHT ON OPPOSITE SIDES IN
CIVIL WARS, THERE ARE WARS, WE
HAVE CEMETERIES IN THE UNITED
STATES WHERE BROTHERS WHO HAVE
FOUGHT IN WARS TOGETHER BURIED
SIDE-BY-SIDE, I'VE NEVER HEARD
ANYTHING LIKE THIS BEFORE, WHERE
BROTHERS HAVE BEEN TORTURED
TOGETHER AND BURIED ALIVE
TOGETHER AND THEN ONE SURVIVES.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THIS SOLDIER'S
HATRED OF THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE JUST THROUGH A SECOND
EFFECT, I FEEL THE SAME HATRED.
IT'S JUST DESPICABLE.
IT'S INHUMAN AND THEY SHOULD BE
PUNISHED FOR IT.
>> SO WHAT ABOUT WHAT'S COMING
OUT OF MARIUPOL?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THE
DEEPLY WOUNDED SURVIVED, YOU
KNOW, TALK TO GET SOME OF THE
FAMILIES THERE.
SOME OF THESE SOLDIERS WERE
INCREDIBLY WOUNDED, WE DON'T
KNOW HOW SURVIVED.
WE DO FEEL THE SURVIVORS ARE NOW
COMING OUT AND THAT IS A
BLESSING FOR THEIR FAMILIES, WE
HOPE.
WE HOPE THEY WILL SURVIVE.
HOWEVER, IT DOES MEAN THAT
RUSSIA NOW HAS FULL AND FORMAL
CONTROL OF MARIUPOL.
THAT IS EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT
AND I WONDER, GENERAL, IF YOU
CAN PUT IT IN CONTEXT.
I KNOW WE HEAR IN PLACES
RUSSIANS NOT MAKING THE PROGRESS
THEY WANT, LOSE TOOTH
UKRAINIANS, NOT FORDING RIVERS,
YET ARE NOW IN CONTROL OF
MARIUPOL WHICH IS A CRUCIAL CITY
THAT GIVES THEM BLACK SEA ACCESS
AND A LANDBRIDGE TO CRIMEA, HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT?
>> WELL I PUSH BACK ON THE
PREMISE A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE IN FULL
CONTROL OF IT YET.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 300 OR SO
WOUNDED SOLDIERS, CERTAINLY AMP
UTEE, BURN VICTIMS, GUNSHOT
WOUNDS, BUT THERE ARE STILL
FIGHTERS IN THAT ASOVSTAL STEEL
PLANT.
>> YES.
>> AND THEY HAVE HELD OVER
12,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS FOR A
PERIOD OF TWO MONTHS AT THAT
SITE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE HCH THIS IS
GOING TO BE REFLECTIVE OF WHAT
THE UNITED STATES DID IN PEARL
HARBOR.
THIS WILL BE THE SORT OF THING
WHERE UKRAINE WILL RISE LIKE A
PHOENIX FROM THIS AND SAY THESE
WERE THE HEROS OF OUR NATION
THAT PREVENTED RUSSIAN FORCES TO
GO TO THE DONETSK AND OTHER
AREAS IN THE DONBAS TO FIGHT.
THEY PREVENTED THAT FROM
HAPPENING FOR TWO MONTHS AND
THAT IS A CRITICAL FACTOR IN
WAR, WHEN YOU CAN TAKE FORCES
OFF THE FRONT LINE OF THE
BATTLEFIELD AND HOLD THEM IN
PLACE TO CONDUCT THESE KIND OF
OPERATIONS.
>> AND CRITICAL FOR SO FEW TO
HOLD OFF SO MANY, AND THOSE
DOING THE HOLDING OFF, WE SP